ni policía ni islamistas el pueblo
quiere revolución es uno de los gritos
en túnez diez años después de la
primavera árabe la crisis es aún peor
también la represión 1200 jóvenes entre
15 y 25 años han sido detenidos desde el
14 de enero si sales a protestar morirás
yo hace la escuela morirás en este país
todo lo que hagas estará condenado te a
muerte siempre hay represión policial
este sábado se repitió el patrón de las
últimas semanas en túnez la capital y en
otras ciudades del país durante el día
protestas por la situación social cuando
llega la noche disturbios en un país
donde el tercio de los jóvenes está
desempleado a dónde va a túnez que se
vayan todos los políticos y nos dejen en
paz ocuparemos las calles o nosotros o
ellos el estallido comenzó el 14 de
enero cuando se conmemoraban 10 años de
la expulsión del dictador ben alí el
proceso de democratización no ha acabado
de consolidarse y en los últimos meses
la crisis política económica y laboral
se ha agravado con la pandemia del cob y
19 que en las últimas jornadas ha
llegado
más de 100 muertos diarios las protestas
se concentran en los barrios
trabajadores y la respuesta del gobierno
tecnócrata está siendo represión y
toques de queda por el virus en la
crisis más grave crea de 1.011 con una
generación más castigada que se ve
obligada a mirar más allá como los cerca
de 13 mil tunecinos que salieron en 2020
de forma irregular en su mayoría hacia
italia